remember video is a whole bunch of
images and a whole bunch of audio slam
together okay so if you want to work out
the size of a video file the first thing
you need to know is the audio data okay
for instance if it's a movie you know is
a surround sound that kind of thing once
you do that you work that part out on
tone that's fine but that you don't deal
with the visual right so remember that a
video is just a series of images yeah so
if you start with your image data namely
your resolution and your bit depth okay
so that tells you one single frame but
to make it a movie and to fool your
diffic this motion right you need a
whole bunch images right so how many
images will you have what what piece of
information will tell you that yeah good
okay now because this image data is just
one and this frame rate is a rate you're
gonna need to know how many frames so
again you've got to bring your length
which you would have gotten before in
red okay so to work out the size of the
video work out your audio first then
work out your image and then Adam and
that'll be the size of your video file
that's it now let me emphasize again
what you need to produce as your answer
is just this pioneer this gigantic
fraction okay for yourself for your own
sake even though it's not to do with the
marks you might like to put in these
[ __ ] who you like okay have I checked
off this have I converted to the right
units uh I got all the bits and pieces
there have I forgotten about anything I
think that's really helpful the red bits
you know those writers in don't get
remarks like yeah I know these things
but I can't write it correctly but it
helps me remember you actually got all
the rapid and checking off okay any
questions
yeah
yeah okay so what's this bitter
it's about converting to kilo kilo bits
per second so it means okay each
individual second how many bits is it
got that's going to be an enormous
number so we convert it into kilo bits
per second that's a little common to a
number so this is uncompressed CD audio
that 1,400 and what we get off iTunes is
like 128 or 256 so you can see it's been
squash down a lot but it still sounds
pretty good okay good question anything
else yep yep okay so I've got four here
four four minutes
but all of these like hurts right is how
many signals per second not how many
signals per minute so therefore I need
to do not how many minutes my tract is
but how many seconds it is anything else
yeah yeah so there's a good question
I guess it's this for the same reason
that humans are weighted kilograms
because if we may when your grams it
would be like I'm so fat I'm thousands
in here I think it's just it just
produces conveniently comparable numbers
tens of thousands of grams
you get the idea so why kilobits per
second not not really yeah okay all
right right yeah that's a good question
um I guess because typical file sizes
for songs are in the megabytes right and
typical bit rates for typical songs are
in the kilo bits it's just sort of I
mean you know I could measure what's the
distance we're sitting to Melbourne in
centimeters or feet I could but the
numbers they're not very helpful really
they're just excessively that or I could
measure in lightyears that's also not
very helpful because like yeah it's
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
one light-years to Melvin like it's not
a useful measure so I think they're just
trying to make the the size of the
numbers convenient